okay let's talk about the competition
here you've shown concern about Google
and Microsoft with open AI developing uh
AGI how can you help ensure with xai and
uh Tesla AI work that it doesn't become
a competitive race to AGI but instead is
a collaborative development of safe
AGI well I mean I've been pushing for
some kind of regulatory oversight for a
long time I've been somewhat of a
Cassandra on the subject for over a
decade
um I think we want to be very careful in
how we develop AI
um it's it's a it's a great power and
with great power comes great
responsibility um I think it it would be
wise for us to have at least um an
objective third party who can be like a
referee that can go in and understand
what the various leading players are
doing with a
and even if there's no enforcement
ability they should they can at
least voice concerns mhm um
publicly um you know Jeff Hinton for
example left Google and he voiced strong
concerns but now he's not at Google
anymore so who's going to voice the
concerns so I think I think there's I I
I like I you know Tesla gets a lot of
regulatory oversight on the automotive
front I we're subject to I think over
100 Regulatory Agencies domestically and
internationally it's a lot um you could
fill this room with the old regulations
that Tesla has to adhere to for
automotive um same is true in you know
for rockets and for you
know um currently the limiting factor
for SpaceX for Starship launch is
regulatory approval uh the fa has
actually given their approval but we're
waiting for fish and wildlife to uh
finish their analysis and give their
approval that's why I posted I want to
buy a fish license
on which also refers the Monty Python
cetch
yeah like why do you need a license for
your fish I I don't
know according to the rules I'm told you
need some sort of fish license or
something we effectively need a fish
license to go to
Rocket and I'm like wait a second how
did the fish come into the picture yeah
um I mean so some of the things like
that that it's I feel like are so absurd
that I want to do like comedy sketch and
Flash at the bottom this is all real
this is actually what happened um you
know one of the things that was a bit of
a challenge at one point is that they
were worried about uh our rocket hitting
a shock MH and um now the ocean's very
big and uh halfen you see shocks uh not
that often you know as a percentage of
ocean surface area shocks basically 0
zero and and and so then will then we
said well how will we calculate the
probability of telling a shark and
they're like well we can't give you that
information because they're worried
about shark hunt shark fin Hunters uh
going in hunting sharks I say well how
are we supposed to we're on the horns of
a dilemma then
um then they said well there's another
part of Fish Wildlife that can can do
this analysis and like well why don't
you give them the data like we don't
they don't we don't trust them like
excuse me you don't they're literally in
your department again this is actually
what happened um and uh and and and can
you do an NDA or
something eventually they managed to
solve the internal quandry and indeed uh
the probability of of ating a shock is
essentially zero um then there's another
organization that I didn't realize
existed until uh you know a few months
ago uh that cares about whether you we
would potentially hit a whale in
international waters now again you look
at the surface of the look at the look
at the Pacific and say what percentage
of the Pacific consists of whale like it
give you a big picture and like point
out all the whales in this picture I'm
like I don't see any
whales like basically 0% um and if AR
does hit a whale which is extremely
unlikely beyond all belief um that is
the the Fate haded that's a well has
some seriously bad luck you know it's
like least lucky wh ever um and um I
mean this is quite
absurd bureaucracy the bureaucracy of
this however it emerged yes well I mean
one one of the things that's pretty wild
is um for launching out of vburg in
California we had to they were worried
about uh seal procreation whether the
seals would be dismayed by the Sonic
booms um now there' have been a lot of
rockets launched out of vook and the
seal population has uh steadily
increased um so if anything rocket booms
are an eort easc um based on the
evidence if you to correlate rocket
launchers with uh sealed population um
nonetheless we were forced to kidnap a
seal strap it to a
board put headphones on the seal and
play Sonic Boom sounds to it to see if
it would be
distressed this is an actual thing that
happened this is actually real I have
pictures I would love to see this
yeah there I mean sorry there's a seal
with
headphones yes it's a seal with
headphones strapped to a board and and
like the okay now the amazing part is
how calm the seal was yeah because if I
was a seal be like this is the
end they're definitely going to eat me
yeah um how old the seal when seal goes
back to other you know seal friends
how's they going to explain that they're
never going to believe him never going
to believe him that's why I'm like well
you know it's sort of like it's like
getting kidnapped by aliens and getting
anal probe you
know you come back and I swear to God I
could kidnapped my aliens and they stuck
anal Pro in my butt and people like no
they didn't that's ridiculous Seal Seal
buddies are never going to believe him
that he gets sted to a Ward and they put
headphones on his
ears and then let him
go twice by the way we had to do it
twice they let him go twice we had to
Capt the same seal well no different
seal
okay did you uh did you get a seal of
approval yeah exactly a seal of approval
no I mean this is this is like I don't
think the public is quite aware of the
the madness that goes
on yeah yeah it's absurd freaking seals
with freaking headphones I mean this is
the I it's a good encapsulation of of
the absurdity of human civilization
seals and headphones
yes
that